I spent an entire life look at me look
at me look at me look at me look at me
look at me look at me look at me look at
me look at me look at me look at me look
at me look at me look at me look at me
look at me look at me look at me don't
touch you die look at me look at me look
at me give me I mean look at me look at
me
Hey look at me look at me look at me oh
look look at me look at me look at me
Forrest look at me son look at me why
don't you look at me look at me look at
me I mean look at me look at me look at
me you're not gonna look at me listen to
me look at me and talk to me look at me
hear what you know look at me look at me
I mean look at me look at me look look
him in the eye look at me when I'm
talking to you look at the winner talk
to you look at me I'm his sexy [ __ ]
look at me I'm a big fat slob look at me
look at me look at me stop look at me
Jean
go ahead wait don't look at me Marla
look at me mark look at me can't really
look at me well just look at me Martin
look at me Mac look at me she won't look
at me
Rox look at me Toni look at me Frank
look at me well look at me Paul
look at me look at me well
look at me look at me down look at me
Jimmy
look at me to me look at me Katie look
at me ray look at me ray look at me look
at me Hector
give me okay look at me look at me look
at me look at me look at me look at me
look at me look at me look at me no what
look at me look at me look at me look at
me look at me really look at me look at
me look at me look at me look at me look
at me now Hey look at me look at me babe
look at me look at me you sloppy [ __ ]
look at me
open your eyes and look at me I mean
look at me come on look at me look at me
look at me look at me now look at me
look at me look at me what are you
looking at Butthead